on va pouvoir traire la vache donc ici
la traite et mécanisée c'est un appareil
qui va prélever l'eau et de la vache sa
part elle s'appelle une griffe à traire
ce que je tient dans la main
qui n'a pas un jour rêvé de devenir
agriculteur
l'idée a sans aucun doute effleuré
l'esprit des petites têtes présentes le
week-end dernier au marché du pari
fermier à la bergerie de rambouillet des
étoiles plein les yeux
les enfants sont repartis instruit au
début les bras et 2,27 et les balles
pour faire levier tombé à quai à
manfesté ya des machines exprès pour
elle et lâche le pari fermier ressemble
fort à un mini salon de l'agriculture
depuis 17 ans outre la traite des vaches
on y apprend à soigner à mes poney ou
encore à dresser des chiens de berger
c'est hyper intéressant du coup pour les
gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude de voir
des fermes ce que c'est il ya pas mal
d'animaux différents avoir après les
tables direction le marché où une
centaine de producteurs avaient monté
leurs étals rillettes confiture
saucisson d'autruche tous les produits
vendus ici le sont en circuits courts
ils proviennent directement des
exploitations je propose des terrines à
l'autruche 1 puisque on transforme tous
nos produits nous mêmes des terrines du
saucisson la base d'autruche de
l'enduire on a une clientèle très fidèle
je compte les gens veulent se
réapproprier leur alimentation souhaite
connaître l'origine des produits plus
qu'honnête si possible les producteurs
qui les ont élaborées et donc on a
effectivement dans cette dynamique 1 on
est vraiment dans le vent d'histoire on
a été des précurseurs
pendant trois jours les yvelinois ont pu
découvrir ou redécouvrir la fabrication
maison de certains produits et goûter à
des nouveautés une pause enchanté avant
le retour au supermarché